after last night's World Cup result but
the truth is there isn't that much to be
found throughout this month there'll be
strikes in huge swathes of our Public
Services it will of course be very
disruptive people traveling for
Christmas and economically damaging when
we're already in recession but with
nurses and ambulance staff joining the
action there are now real fears for an
NHS already in serious crisis long
before the worst of the winter there are
a few more dangerous things for a
government than the sense that the
country is grinding to a halt while
number 10 will be pleased to have calm
the chaos of recent month there is real
Peril in the weeks ahead much to discuss
on a chilly morning here in Westminster
with my guests we are talking to the
foreign secretary James cleverley in
just a moment
and with the NHS and the seemingly
perpetual and growing crisis I'll talk
to Labor's Shadow Health secretary
where's treated
also staying with the NHS and given
those upcoming nurse and ambulance
strikes plus the strep A outbreak and
the worst of the winter yet to come I'll
talk to the deputy chair of the British
Medical Association that's Dr Emma
Brunswick
with 70 unions involved in so many
disputes we'll talk to Kevin Rowan of
the trades Union Congress and with yet
more allegations of bad behavior
misconduct and worse here in Westminster
I'll be joined by the former special
advisor to not one but two chancellors
Sonja Khan
[Music]
well there is much on the domestic
agenda to trouble the government strikes
in so many parts of the public sector
the Health Service and real danger and
the ongoing cost of living crisis all
that as the global situation remains
tense with the war in Ukraine entering a
grim winter and relations with Russia
and China as cold as ever so a good time
to talk to the foreign secretary James
cleverley who will give his first major
policy speech in the job tomorrow we
started by discussing the upcoming
strikes
I'm going to start with a nurse's stride
the Royal College of Nursing say that
they want to meet the health secretary
to stop the strike they say they've
offered to negotiate five times but the
health secretary has turned them down
this is what Pat Cullen their general
secretary said he said negotiate she
said sorry negotiate with the nurses and
avoid this stride five times my offer to
negotiate has been turned down I will
press pause on it when the health
secretary says he will negotiate
seriously on our dispute this year that
means each of us giving some ground
what members of the public think it's
extraordinary the health secretary
doesn't appear willing to sit down with
the nurses well the health secretary has
said that he is of course happy to meet
he said his door is open he said that in
the article that he wrote today I think
people need to understand though that
the negotiation on pay is done by an
independent pay review body and so often
we see people saying we need to take the
politics out of this these things need
to be done by independent professionals
so he put in place an independent pay
review body we've accepted and
implemented their findings in full of
course the health secretary wants to
talk to the profession about how we can
make the about make the job better how
we can improve the NHS performance for
everybody but ultimately pay is decided
by an independent people independent pay
bodies in a moment but but the fact of
the matter is you know if they're
willing to sit down and talk to the
health secretary and they've said that
they are five times isn't he hiding
behind this independent pay review body
you know he should meet shouldn't he
well he said he's willing to meet them
but again we're saying you're willing to
meet them and they're not meeting them
no but but the point is somebody meet
them but the point is
um uh meetings are different from Pain
negotiations and through most of my time
when I've been involved in politics
people have said they want they they
keep saying they want to take the
politics out of this we massively value
massively value the work that health
professionals do my mother was a midwife
like many many people in the country
I've got uh good friends uh who are who
are members who are members who are
members who are who are uh health
professionals and we value them
enormously But ultimately independent
bodies are there for a reason is to take
the politics out of this kind of stuff
and and and we respect the Judgment they
made we're implementing it but there is
politics in this isn't there and in the
end it's the government that controls
the person's strengths and you talk
about these independent pay review
bodies but when they made these pay
recommendations this was before
inflation had gone up to the level as it
is their figures are some would say
really woefully out of date and these
are bodies that are appointed by the
government often staffed by people
who've got a background within the NHS
themselves and management so some would
say you know question really whether
they are that independent but
fundamentally doesn't the government
need to talk to the people that they're
negotiating with before they even get to
the point of talking numbers they need
to physically sit down and negotiate
with the nurses well so I I think it's
uh I I don't think it's right at all to
question the independence of these
bodies as you say they are they're often
people from the sectors in which they
are making decisions and and of course
we recognize the uh the the value of the
work that's done by the medical
professions but these independent they
are independent pay review bodies are
there for a reason that's what people
have been calling for as I say for most
of the time that I've been involved in
politics that there's real Independence
in these
and it's really important to recognize
that the the 19.2 percent uh request
would would cost something uh something
in the region of 10 billion pounds to
match just that uh pay award which is
which is which is a larger sum of money
than the 8 billion pounds we're putting
in over the next two years for Health
and Social care to address the backlog
and that's and that's of course the
challenge that we've got to recognize we
are very focused on making sure the NHS
is delivering for the British people we
hugely respect professionals within it
but we have to be sensible it's not
respectful if you're not willing to talk
with them now the RCN have said today
that they are very well that's not the
the health sector is said today that he
is of course willing to talk to them but
the pay negotiations are done through
the internet okay so so will he sit down
with the Royal College of Nursing in the
next day or so and avert the strikes
that we're expecting later this week
well in the op-ed he said his door is
open but we've also made it clear that
the pay negotiation nations are done
through the Independent to pay review
body so he won't negotiate pay with the
nurses he will simply say go back to the
independent pay review body well so the
question I ask is is is do do do we
respect those independent people you
respect them but the fact of the matter
is if if the independent pay review body
is saying one thing and the nurses are
saying another
we've got the health secretary doesn't
appear to be talking to the nurses
directly he's the only one who can solve
but he's the only one who can sit in the
middle and say right this is what they
say this is what you want let's try and
reach a compromise but that is the role
so I mean that is the role of the
independent pay review body it's the the
clues in the name it's independent and
it reviews pay Awards who control the
purse strings they're not the ones who
make the decision it's it's a
recommendation they make it's up to the
government it is a recommendation it's a
recommendation and a recommendation it's
a recommendation and a recommendation
that we have um agreed to implement but
it just doesn't seem that there's any
way to resolve this then if the
government is saying we are simply not
going to move from what the independent
pay review body says we are not willing
to negotiate at all with the nurses
about about what they believe sorry this
question is going around in circles the
point is getting a straight answer sorry
you're not getting an answer you like
but that's different I'm giving you a
straight something to understand why the
independent people
independent pay review bodies were
created to resolve differences between
the uh the the bodies that seeking uh
pay whether they be in the health
profession teaching profession other
professions and the government that hold
the purse strings they are the
adjudicator they were created they are
independent of government they are
staffed by experts that is why they
exist they make recommendations and in
this instance the government has
accepted the recommendation fully but
the nurses don't accept it and it seems
therefore that there is no way to move
forward from this but as I said the the
health secretary has set his door is
open uh he wants to talk to the health
professionals about how we how we drive
performance in the NHS how we make sure
that it's a job that uh that they want
to uh that they want to do that all
these things but
as I say the independent pay review
bodies do what we ask them to do which
is to review pay independent the
government we accept their
recommendations and ambulance staff are
out on strike this week do you think
people will die because of it well we we
want to make sure that uh people are
safe we very much regret the fact that
um the ambulance service and another key
public services are are going on strike
we recognize there is huge amount of
pressure on on everybody everybody
because of covert because of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and the inflationary
price uh pressures that put on household
prices we we do recognize that but the
role of the ambulance service is
important we are looking at contingency
planning to make sure that we can keep
people safe and people should rely on
the NHS they should call 999 if there's
a problem and will work to make sure
that they can be moved from where they
are to where they need to be treated if
people die because they can't get
ambulances who do you think well I'm not
gonna I'm not I'm not to speculate on
that we are putting contingency plans in
place we will be working to make sure
that people are able to rely on
Emergency Services
let's turn to foreign policy uh
obviously you are making a big major
policy speech as foreign secretary
setting out a doctrine of new
Partnerships farscowing countries
including Asia Africa Latin America
they're not traditional trading partners
of the UK why didn't we trade with them
in the past well it's not just about
trading relationships this is one of the
points I'm going to make in the uh in
the speech trade is an important part of
a bilateral relationship but a good
diplomatic relations in a number of
these countries where we have a
development Partnerships helping them
develop their economies the the point
I'm making is that if you project
forward over the next 15 25 30 years
there are a number of countries
fostering countries who are going to be
increasingly wealthy and therefore
important trade Partners but they are
going to be increasingly influential on
the world stage and I want to make sure
that the the values the principles that
the UK feel strongly about are ones that
we're discussing with these increasingly
uh wealthy yes but influential countries
over the next few decades you talk about
values and principles and let's talk
about Iran it's just carried out its
first execution of a protester for
taking part in dissent against the
regime this is machine shikari he was
charged with holding up traffic
assaulting a guard he's dead
you have talked very tough on on Iran
you've said on Friday you said you want
to hold the country to account you're
imposing sanctions on a small number of
people
but the government's own figures show
that trade with Iran went up 113 over
the last year how do you square that as
foreign secretary you know one hand
you're saying this is Despicable what is
happening here but we're very happy to
trade with the country in fact we're
happy to do more trade with the country
so I think you'll find that that is uh
an increase on a very very very small
figure and obviously where there are uh
when figures are quite yeah 287 million
pounds that we trade with Iran which
which if you look at the trade figures
almost any other countries is is is
almost negligible
um the point is that the uh the response
of the regime to uh protesters
internally is completely unacceptable we
called in the Iranian Ambassador uh last
week we summoned the Iranian of
Ambassador last week to uh to hold him
uh accountable for what's happened we
are sanctioning people who are involved
in human rights abuses as well as the
broader sanctions that are in place uh
as part of our effort to prevent Iran
from acquiring a nuclear weapon
um Iran knows that we feel very very
strongly about this and they should
understand that these are Grassroots
protests from their own people who are
criticizing the Iranian regime for the
oppression of the Iranian people
okay well let's move on to a country
which you do spend even more money with
and that's Saudi Arabia trade with Saudi
Arabia is worth 13.7 billion I noticed
that in this article that you wrote on
Friday you didn't mention Saudi Arabia
81 men were executed there last year and
at the time the foreign office Minister
Alan Duncan said there's a deep
murkiness here that we do not like but
it obviously doesn't stop us dealing
with them
um
up 26 last year the trade with Saudi
Arabia are you proud of being foreign
Secretary of a country that trades with
a country that actually crucifies people
in public well
um I have spoken with the Saudis about
our long-standing principled position uh
on the death penalty as I do with pretty
much all countries around the world that
maintain the death penalty they know
it's a long-standing uh principled
opposition to us Saudi of course uh is
not just economically but but culturally
religiously and Incredibly important
influential country in the Middle East
uh and further it's incredibly important
that we maintain an ongoing bilateral
relationship uh with uh with Saudi some
of that includes trade but also in terms
of security
counter-terrorism work and when we have
a relationship with the country of
course we highlight where there are
differences and on this issue we have
very very deep differences but we also
seek to find the areas where we can
exert influence and we have I have in
fact been supportive of the reform
program that saudi's putting forward and
we have seen real changes over the last
decade I want to see those changes go
further and faster I believe that many
people in the uh in the Saudi government
would like to do so also but you see the
concern
that the British government will deal
with countries that do have
objectionable human rights records if
it's if it's worth it for us and you
you're talking about this new policy
that you're going to embrace lots of
other countries a lot of people will
look at that and say hang on is the
British government now the kind of
government that will deal with these
states and just hold their nose if we
think that it's good for trade well look
you keep referring to trade trade is not
the only element in fact in with many of
these countries it's not the most
significant element at all but the point
I'm making the point I'll make in the in
the speech is that we are in a
competitive global environment a number
of these countries that are developing
fast are becoming as I say increasingly
influential on the world stage not just
economically but but uh you know
politically
um
what's what I'm looking for
um
diplomatically
are being wooed they are being rude they
have choices and either we find a way of
encouraging those countries to move in
the direction that we think is the right
direction uh increase openness
increase you know reform within
themselves as we are doing with Saudi
Arabia and others or we can choose to
detach but those countries will still be
influential those countries will still
be important but those countries will
increasingly increasingly be detached
from us I don't think that's in their
interest and I certainly don't think
it's in the UK's National interest so we
work with we work with countries and
when we have disagreements we highlight
that there's disagreements where we have
opportunities to exert influence we seek
to as a influence as well what about
Egypt a few weeks ago the uh sister of
Allah Abdel fatah the British Egyptian
political prisoner who's held there made
an appeal to the British prime minister
on this program uh to try and get her
brother's release what progress have you
made well the Prime Minister uh spoke
with President CeCe on this issue I've
spoken with the Egyptian foreign
minister on this I know our officials
speak with Egyptian officials on this
regularly as well so we are working we
continue to work on these Consular cases
both in Egypt and and elsewhere we we we
want to make sure that we
um have access to this person who is a
dual Egyptian British national will keep
working
um and sometimes these conversations
done publicly often they are done
privately but I can assure you in the
viewers that we continue working on this
there haven't been any specific
diplomatic consequences have there well
as I say we we do continue to um
to the Egyptians about this I know we're
not alone in doing that okay
literation in Ukraine earlier this week
Vladimir Putin said Russia could reach
agreements about Ukraine in the future
and reading the runes do you think there
is any possibility that it could
potentially be peace talks on the
horizon well ultimately of course we do
want to see peace in Ukraine we see the
brutalization of the Ukrainian people we
see the impact that that war is having
on on on grain prices and grain of
availability around the world I've just
come back from Ethiopia uh where
um the the impact of the war in Ukraine
is is being felt with regard to food
insecurity so of course we want to see
this resolved but we have always made
the case I have always made the case
that any negotiations need to be real
they need to be meaningful they can't
just be a fig leaf for Russian
re-armament and further recruitment of
of soldiers whether that be from the
Wagner group or trawling prisons in
Russia so of course we do want to see
peace talks but they need to be
meaningful and ultimately the content of
those uh peace talks the the threshold
uh that uh that might be met in terms of
bringing peace has got to be decided by
the Ukrainian people the Ukrainian
president because of course they're the
ones whose sons and daughters are being
killed in this world do you sense
there's any changes on that front do you
sense that it could be the possibility
that there are talks well at the moment
I'm not really seeing anything coming
from the Russian side that gives me
confidence that uh Vladimir Putin is
entering these talks in good faith the
The Wider rhetoric is still very uh
confrontational But ultimately as I say
we want to see this resolved we would
prefer to see it resolved sooner rather
than later but that resolution's got to
be meaningful
what if Russia pulled back to just
occupying Crimea would that in your mind
be a Fair basis to have peace talks so I
I don't want to I don't want to start
setting the conditions for what Ukraine
and the Ukrainian people should accept
ultimately it's their country that
they're defending it's their sons and
daughters that have been lost it's their
homes their infrastructure that has been
damaged by
um Vladimir Putin's Invasion and it's up
for them to decide the circumstances
under which they'll be willing to
negotiate for peace okay
um lots of other stories in the news
this week including a documentary that's
come out of America Harry and Megan I
don't know if you've had a chance to see
it with your busy schedule
um given that the row over that and also
comments made by a member of the the
public at a reception at the palace a
couple of weeks ago do you think the
royal family has a problem with racism
well I'm not gonna I'm not going to
discuss the documentary not least
because
um when I get a spare moment I I'm
trying to catch up with stranger things
when I when I watch television rather
than rather than that particular some of
your colleagues think they should lose
their titles so
um
my view in all the interactions that I
have had with the royal family and I do
have the opportunity to do so more than
most because of my role as foreign
secretary
um I've I've seen a a group of people
who are passionate about supporting the
Britain as it is
um the uh the the King has spoken in the
past when he was Prince of Wales about
uh about the wonder that is the
Multicultural nature of this uh country
I get to travel the world and when you
do you get to look back at the UK as
others see us and I'm very proud of what
I see I see a a very well integrated
multi-ethnic
um a country that I think can be very
proud of its diverse Heritage and I
think the Royal Family's attitude to
this country reflects the modern country
that we that we see that's my personal
experience but I also think that that is
something that the whole world sees when
they look at us
they also look at us in terms of
football did you get a chance to watch
it last night oh I did I did and I know
exactly what's going to happen next my
my my my good friend the French prime
minister was sending me uh little little
messages uh just before she boarded a
flight so I know that she didn't watch
the game because she was in the air I'm
dreading to think when she wakes up uh
this morning what what uh what messages
await me
um look it was it was a good match I
think uh I think France had the first
half
England had the second half
um I I mean I I think I think our boys
did incredibly incredibly well we should
be really proud of them tough result but
we should be proud of them and the Anton
cordial remains in place
uh you know wishing France well for the
next round I mean some people would say
should he be doing that but look um
sport brings people together I mean
that's that's the point sport brings
people together
um it was a it was a good match I
um I've got my I got my eye on Morocco I
just I there's something there and it's
incredibly exciting African African team
uh going that far
um
this is yeah the round of eight is um is
is I think always the most exciting bit
of the tournament typically as you get
close to the final it gets everyone gets
a little bit more cautious
um but uh but yeah look there's some
really good thing there is some really
interesting results could be interesting
final
James Bradley thank you very much thank
you
well that was the foreign secretary
James cleverley uh let's get the view
from labor now I can talk to the shadow
Health secretary where's streeting uh Mr
Street in really good to talk to you
today thanks very much for joining us
especially giving us good morning is
outside
um we're talking uh about aside from the
football uh the state of the NHS strikes
uh the current state of the NHS and and
you've written an interesting piece in
the Sunday Telegraph today
um you say that after the pandemic there
are no quick fixes for the NHS and that
you're terrified by the state of it what
would labor do first and why
so the center of Labor's plans to make
the NHS fit for the future is the
biggest expansion of the NHS Workforce
in history Because unless we have the
staff we need we won't be able to give
patients the timely access to care that
they deserve that so that would be the
biggest expansion of the NHS staff in
history doubling the number of medical
school places increasing nursing and
Midwifery clinical training places by
ten thousand five thousand more Health
visitors and doubling the number of
District nurses and we would pay for it
by abolishing the non-dom tax status
because we think that people who make
Britain their home should pay their
taxes here too and this is a fair way of
funding that something that's
desperately needed Because unless you've
got a plan for the workforce you don't
have a plan for the NHS and
unfortunately that's the terrible
situation this government has found
itself in and that's the difference a
labor government would make your critics
would say that that abolishing non-dom
status is something of a cheap shot to
get at the Prime Minister and his
personal circumstances what is the
evidence that it actually would bring in
that money because some would say that
actually the very wealthy will simply
take the best advice and move themselves
and their money elsewhere and deny it to
the treasury and and also that your
plans yes you're talking about far more
staff members which would be enormously
welcomed in the NHS but for example
doctors getting more doctors through the
system this takes years and years you're
talking
solutions that will help in five to ten
years time
so I say a few things in response I mean
firstly the figures we've used in the
analysis we've used is independent
produced by academics at Warwick
University and the London School of
Economics it would generate more than
three billion pounds that's more than
enough to cover the 1.6 billion that our
package would cost and as for these uh
claims that people would just go take
their money and and go somewhere else
why is it that when it comes to taxing
the wealthy it's always far too
difficult but when it comes to picking
the pockets of working people with
punitive tax Rises that seems to be the
conservatives first and last resort and
look we haven't taken this policy to
single out the Prime Minister and his
family actually but there is a case in
point in 10 Downing Street isn't there
of someone who was a non-dom now pays
their taxes here and hasn't left the
country and I think that would be the
case in the vast majority of non-doms
too and while I understand that the
chancellor wants good relation with his
next-door neighbors who doesn't I do
think this is a fair way of funding a
Workforce plan which Jeremy Hunt himself
welcomed when labor first announced it
and he said and these are his words the
smart government's Nick the best ideas
of his opponents well I'm saying this
morning Jeremy you're welcome to Nick
Labor's Workforce plan we need to get
our skates on recruiting the doctors and
nurses and other staff the NHS needs
you're welcome to Nick the plan and in
the meantime Sophie there are things the
government can and should be doing right
now to alleviate the crisis in the NHS
this winter whether that's using spare
beds in the private sector so that we
pay for people to get seen faster so
it's free at the point of use for them
but much quicker using that capacity
available whether it's dealing with the
pensions issues that see doctors leaving
the NHS early retiring early for no
other reason than their pension rules
create a financial disincentive to stay
on or whether it's actually just pulling
their finger out and even where they're
trying to do the right thing like half a
billion pounds to deal with delayed
discharge in Social care do you know not
a penny of that money has hit the front
line yet why because of all the chaos we
saw over the summer changing from Health
secretary to health secretary from prime
minister to prime minister I'm afraid
the conservatives incompetence and chaos
is costing the country dear but there
are things they can and should be doing
we're calling on them to take that
action but ultimately I think it's clear
now after 12 years that the longer the
conservatives are in power the longer
patients will wait you're talking about
the conservatives nicking your ideas but
looking at this this piece that you've
written it seems like you're nicking a
lot of theirs you've just referred to
using the private sector more and some
would be astonished at seeing this
policy coming from from a labor
politician you've also talked about the
BMA who we are going to be talking to
later on in the program as vested
interests you say that they see you as a
heretic for wanting better patient
access and you're going to take them on
um how do you think these lines will go
down with traditional labor voters
well the last Labor government
successfully used the private sector to
bring down NHS waiting list and you know
by the end of that labor government use
of the private sector had fallen
dramatically because the NHS was so good
that people didn't feel the need to go
private any longer and and as for the
question of values I think it's
outrageous we've got a two-tier
healthcare system in this country today
where those who can pay to go private do
and those who can't afford to go private
are left behind or indeed there are some
people that are scrimping and scraping
even getting themselves into dare in
order to get seen faster that's not a
fair and Equitable situation that's not
the NHS living up to its founding
principles and I think it's the right
thing to do to create a Level Playing
Field using empty beds in the private
sector so that people can see be seen
faster and as for the BMA I mean I was
just responding in that interview with
the telegraph to criticism they leveled
at me because despite the fact that I
announced the biggest expansion of NHS
staff in history because I had the
temerity to to say that we should also
expect better service for patients in
exchange for that investment because I I
think that it's unacceptable that people
have to wait on the phone at eight
o'clock in the morning to get through to
GP I have been treated like some kind of
heretic by the BMA and I'm afraid you
know I do understand the pressure that
doctors are under they do a very
difficult job against very difficult
backdrop but what I'm saying is if we're
putting investment into the NHS as the
next Labor government will we have got
to expect a better results for patients
and ultimately it's my job to be the
patience Champion I'm a patient myself
I've had great experience on the NHS
I've also had not great experience on
the NHS I want to make sure that
everyone in this country gets a great
experience and that we've got an NHS
that's fit for the future but but as the
man who could very soon be Health
secretary it doesn't sound like you've
got a really great relationship from the
start with the doctors unions
uh look my I'm always willing to engage
with a BMA in fact on the doctor's
pensions issue where they've made a
reasonable Point as they did on that
issue I'm prepared to run with it but
what I'm not prepared to do is just
accept lower standards for patients
because people think that it's
unachievable to expect that people
should be able to book a GP appointment
online or see the doctor they want to
face to face get faster treatment I do
understand the pressures that are on NHS
staff today that's why we're proposing
to dramatically increase NHS num
Staffing numbers that's why on issues
like retention of the staff we have
we're both urging the government to act
on doctors pensions but also urging them
to be grown up and get around the table
with the unions that are preparing to go
on strike who even at this 11th Hour are
saying there is a deal to be done I mean
the Royal College of Nursing and Unison
have said just last night that if the
government is prepared to sit down and
talk about pay and all of the other
issues they will spend strike action
this week now I think that is an offer
that is too good to refuse and I want
the government to explain why they're
not prepared to sit down and even talk
even though they know that patients will
experience real disruption as a result
of strike actions
that's responsible
earlier and he said that the health
secretary's door is open but that is up
to the independent pay review bodies to
make a ruling on pay
um you also said in this piece that the
energy the government's lines are jokes
there's a joke on that Sophie the
government's line is a complete joke on
that there hasn't been a single minute
of negotiation you've got the General
Secretary of the Royal College of
Nursing and the General Secretary of
Unison saying they will suspend strike
action this week if the government will
talk they've not even said if the
government you know rolls over and
accepts the entirety of their pay demand
they have said very reasonably if the
government talks will be there and will
suspend strike action it is completely
unreasonable for the government not to
want to negotiate and I think they are
spoiling with a fight I think they don't
have a plan for the NHS this winter
they're quite happy to see paramedics
and nurses go on strike because when the
proverbial hits the fan this winter they
are going to blame nurses and paramedics
for an NHS crisis which is squarely the
fault of a conservative government and
12 years of mismanagement I think that's
dangerous I think it's reprehensible I
think it's irresponsible and I think
patients will rightly blame the
government not the unions if these
strikes go ahead okay well let's talk
money then what pay Rises would the
labor party give NHS workers that let's
look at the NHS itself there are nine
bands and NHS payers I'm sure you know
let's look sort of in the middle fan
four-ish a theater support worker this
is the person that holds your hand when
the anesthetics going into your arm make
sure that you're all right make sure the
surgeon has all the tools that they need
they're currently on around 24 to 26 000
pounds a year which is about 12 12 to 13
pounds an hour
what would labor give them what do you
think would be a fair pay rise
so we would be willing to negotiate
Sophie and negotiate on Pay The Wider
terms and conditions and the way that
the independent pay review Body Works
I'm not going to pluck numbers out of
thin air this morning not least because
a labor Government after an election
that's probably going to be in around
two years time
you shouldn't be doing
no no no I don't want to be
misunderstood on that point Sophie what
I said is that we would look at how the
pay review Body Works because when I
have been talking to the RCN Unison GMB
and unite um they raise a whole range of
issues yes around pay and the terms and
conditions that staff are working under
which I think are intolerable but
they've also talked about the
independence of the pay review body and
the way it works I'd be willing to look
at all of those scrap the current issues
engage seriously
it's important that we have independent
pay review bodies and I think the unions
have raised some legitimate concerns
about how they work I'd be willing to
look at that but what I'm not prepared
to do Sophie this morning is to create
hostages to Fortune and worse still make
promises for two years time that I may
not be able to keep because when I come
on your program and say the labor party
will deliver the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history is because I can
guarantee what it would cost how we
would pay for it and the decision it
would make that's the approach we're
taking to all of our policies and
sometimes I know it's frustrating for
people who want us to go further faster
and for all of the campaign and Lobby
groups who want us to adopt this policy
or that policy but the conservatives
have crashed the economy the public
finances are in a real mess and I want
to make sure as all of us in the labor
party do that when we go into the
election the public can have confidence
events that we can keep the promises
that we make so my message to the
government today is get around the table
of the unions you you convert strike
action the unions are being entirely
reasonable on this negotiate today avert
strike action and will be willing to
talk to the unions about how we make
sure that the staff who are currently in
the NHS feel valued how we get the
economy growing again so that we can
invest in our public services and
improve people's pay without having to
resort to higher taxes that the
conservatives had and and to work
together on the NHS said it's fit for
the future
okay we're nearly out of time but I just
wanted to ask you a little bit about the
relationship between the labor party and
the unions we've had further allegations
this week about the United Union two
reports being handed over to the police
um from its own review and into what
happened there when you look at the
allegations that there are do you think
it's time for the labor party to step
back from from the way it is funded
relying on the unions for so much of its
funding do you think it is time to to
think again about how your party is
funded
what will two things firstly I think the
current General Secretary of unite
Sharon Graham deserves enormous credit
for being willing to open the books and
go through them call in the
investigators to make sure that her
members Subs are properly used and I
think the findings we've seen are deeply
worrying but you know it takes guts to
uncover the levels of of wrongdoing that
appear to have taken place in unite and
I think she deserves credit for that the
second thing is the labor party was
founded by the trade unions to stand up
for the interests of working people that
throughout our history I think has been
a strength we don't always agree we
can't always say yes to every demand
that the trade unions make but I think
what the trade Union link has done
throughout Labor's history is root Us in
the experiences and the interests of
ordinary working people who without the
labor party would not have a voice in
British politics because as a
conservatives have shown us throughout
their their history they act in the
interests of a privileged few at the top
the labor party exists to serve the
interests of the many that's the
fundamental dividing line in British
politics and that has never been more
true than it is today
okay we're streaming very good to talk
to you thank you very much
you're watching Sophie Ridge on Sunday
if you are confused I am of course not
Sophie I am Jane and I'm with you for
the rest of the program uh that was uh
where's streeting uh making it very
clear that he thinks the government
should get around the table and talk to
the nurses just before I spoke to the
foreign secretary James cleverley who
told me that the health secretary's door
was open to talks with the unions but
that all discussions about pay need to
go through the pay review body so no
signs of that dispute it seems being
resolved imminently
still to come on the program this
morning
[Music]
in just a moment we'll delve deeper into
the crisis in the NHS I'll talk to the
deputy chair of the British Medical
Association Council Dr Emma Brunswick
and a little later we'll discuss the
strikes across the public sector with
Kevin Rowan of the trades Union Congress
plus we'll get some immediate reaction
from our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates he's got his Christmas lights out
he's watching all our interviews and
we'll talk to Sam a little bit later on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
service which seems to be in an
ever-growing crisis as waiting times and
lists grow well before the usual winter
crisis nurses and ambulance staff will
walk out on strike this month and Junior
doctors will be balloted on action soon
that will be held by the British Medical
Association which is both the Trade
union and professional bodies for
doctors in the UK it's Council Deputy
chair Dr Emma runswick joins me now very
good to talk to you we just spoke to Wes
streeting their Shadow Health Minister
he says he's not afraid to take you on
he calls you vested interests and says
that you think he's a heretic for
wanting better patient access are you
concerned that you perhaps don't have as
good a relationship as you should with
the man who may well be Health secretary
very soon well certainly I'm
disappointed in the the rhetoric that
that Mr streeting is adopting you know
this is applying to charges that you've
made against him
well this this morning he's he's said in
the telegraph that NHS staff are looking
for for something for nothing and I
think I think my members and and many
health staff across the UK will be
absolutely gobsmacked by that because we
are giving everything and receiving less
than nothing in return pay cuts real
terms pay cuts in return
and we agree that we want a Better
Health Service you know we're we're
working in it I see patients you know if
every week who have been waiting for a
long time to see us and it's really
devastating working in that that
situation where we know we're not
providing the standards of care that we
want to be the solution isn't to attack
the staff the solution is to attack the
government who are who are absolutely
responsible and for for driving our
service into the ground
uh as I say surely the the solution is
fixing this isn't it it's sitting down
talking about it and finding a solution
rather than attacking anybody do you
feel well absolutely you can talk to the
government this is between
um you know attacking and blaming NHS
staff and directing the blame where it
really is is deserved at the feet of the
government then then I think Mr Streeter
needs to need to really focus on the
government who are responsible for the
for the problems we face
there have been dire warnings from all
parts of the NHS and and some of the
statistics that have been you know in
the news so much over the last few days
in all of your times working in the NHS
have you ever seen it this bad
no I think I think the honest answer is
no we haven't ever seen it this bad
we've got you know such extreme levels
of vacancy you know about 10 000 doctors
missing in Secretary care alone 47 000
nurses missing we've got 1 900 GPS fewer
than we did in in 2015 and provided more
appointments than ever so 32 million
appointments provided by those GPS this
year and yet we absolutely can't meet
the demand that we have on the service
um and that's a whole mixture of factors
but it means that we can't do as as well
as we would want to for patients and you
know we've we hear all of the real
patient stories that underlines that
misery for us and it and it impacts on
our mental health and our well-being as
well and that's why so many are leaving
one of the reasons so many are leaving
if we want to fix those problems we
really have to tackle the issues of pay
pensions and working conditions that are
forcing staff out it's not just about
recruitment at the bottom end it's about
keeping the staff who are already in the
service and providing training to our
younger colleagues
do you think the NHS can cope this
winter
well the NHS is already collapsing and
has been for some some time now so are
we going to see you know worsening of
that collapse as demand increases this
winter and we have another covert wave
we have another flu wave we have and
this the strep a both you know situation
and the Panic associated with it but are
we going to see worsening a worsening
situation I'm almost certain of that and
what can the government do you think
more people will die
uh I do I do think more people will die
and I don't think
um you know this that's not something
that we that we want and there are some
solutions to that
um but the currently the government
won't even speak to us so we're in a
we're in a really difficult difficult
situation and none of us want to be in
as health workers we've all committed to
providing you know excellent patient
care we're aware that we're not able to
do that at the minute and we're doing
our best you know we're driving
ourselves into the ground trying to
provide that and we're working with each
other and increasingly we're organizing
to take a stand over our service and we
want our profession and you know for
doctors we want our profession to be
valued and and we want our skills across
the Health Service to be valued we want
the government and and patients from the
public to realize that we are trying but
also we're reaching the point where we
have to take action because if we don't
do anything it will keep getting worse
and you're balloting your members for a
pay rise for junior doctors
um what do you think the likelihood is
that they will go out on strike in the
new year
I think it's likely unless the
government is willing to negotiate with
us about pay so we're asking for a
reversal of a pay cut we've had you know
a pay cut for junior doctors of 26.1
since 2008 and so over a quarter of our
pay has been lost and this year again
we've received two percent pay award
which is about 10 less than inflation
that's another month working for free
I'll work in a whole month for free
compared to last year
you won't even say sorry yeah forgive me
we haven't got a huge amount of time but
but what what number would you like if
you would if your dream number that the
government would give you
but we're looking for pay restoration so
restoration of that pay cut yeah
absolutely but it's only a lot for the
government will give you a 25 pay rise
well it's it's only as steep as the
money that has been cut from us as only
as steep as the money that we've lost so
if the government as you know the
government has continued to give us
below inflation uh pay Awards year after
year you know claps do not pay the bills
you know we are at a point now where we
are you know 10 000 doctors short in
secondary care alone
1900 fewer GPS than we've had in the
past we we really need to tackle the
problems of keeping staff in the service
and whether that's doctors nurses
ambulance staff you know paramedics
radiographers the whole team really need
to understand and to and to be valued by
the government and and therefore value
our patients and the service that we're
providing to them as well so to be clear
on this program you're saying you want a
25 pay increase
okay so if as inflation changes and we
will continue to seek restoration of the
losses that we've had okay
but you're saying that's 25 I mean as
you referred to the Goodwill that that
there was throughout covert and the
Clapping on the doorsteps many in the
country would love to see those in the
medical profession getting a pay rise
but you also said that you think people
will die partly as a result of the
strikes partly as a result of of the
state that the NHS is in over of this
winter do you think that there's going
to be a change are you worried that that
the public will perhaps not be quite as
much in love with the NHS after a few
weeks of strikes as they are now I think
that the public
um really understand
that our desire for investment in health
workers and the Health Service
is fundamentally about the wanting to be
able to provide and a really excellent
standard of care for patients that's
what it's about there's a there's an
absolute link between investment and the
Health Service and the quality of care
we're able to provide we all know that
we're we're not currently providing that
standard of care we want to be able to
do better
and therefore we are we are stack taking
a stand and asking the government to
invest in in us and the service that we
provide I think the public know that and
I think it's really clear to them you
know if if you don't trust doctors when
you're when you're asking this question
then ask the nurses if you don't trust
the nurses then ask the paramedics if
you don't ask you know trust the
paramedics and there's so many of us who
are now facing this this same set of
difficulties having faced such attacks
on our on our pay on our conditions and
on our service the service that we
provide to you over such a long period
of time there's so many of us now facing
these difficulties all of us have come
to the same conclusion and all of us are
looking for and for change and I think
that the public and patients will
understand that
okay and just to be clear you do think
that it's very likely a junior doctors
will go and strike in the new year
I do unless there is change from the
government you know it's in the
government scale
to get to negotiate and that was very
clear thank you very much Dr emerence
with Deputy chair of the BMA thank you
very much
thank you
well as usual the take will follow this
program just after 9 30. our chance to
analyze today's interviews and talk
through any news lines with our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates let's get a
quick take from Sam now on what stood
out for him so far this morning Sam Sam
what have you made of the interview so
far
good morning Jane well last night the
RCN the Royal College of nurses and
Unison suggested that they would call
off the strike for nurses in England
Wales and Northern Ireland that begin on
Thursday even if the government's pay
offer was below inflation this morning
talking to you James cleverley rejected
the idea that ministers might get
involved with negotiating pay with
nurses to call off this strike so that's
a major moment the government rejecting
what appeared to be a fig Leaf last
night we've already heard labor
criticize that decision interesting
hearing James cleverley's reasoning he
says it's not foreign ministers to
negotiate on pay up to a point Lord
copper the pay review body reported last
June when inflation was lower pay review
bodies only provide as you were saying
to him recommendations ministers often
change it and up in Scotland actually
they went up beyond the Scottish
government went beyond what the pay
review body suggested nationally and
there isn't a strike there so ministers
will be in the frame for this decision
this will increase the political
temperature as a result of the
interviews this morning
Sam thanks very much
well you've no doubt heard the term
winter of discontent being thrown around
at the moment but are things really as
bad as the late 1970s and just how much
could it worse could it get in coming
months Britain's biggest unions unite
Unison the GMB rmt PCS CWU are taking
hundreds of thousands of workers out on
strike across Public Services the
transport Network and The Wider economy
it'll cause huge disruption and further
damage an economy struggling with
soaring inflation let's now talk to the
head of public services at the
organization that resent represents all
trade unions the TUC that's Kevin Rowan
and he joins me now um Mr own a very
good to talk to you today thanks for
joining us from up North there are
people who will not be able to travel
after horrendous periods being apart
since covert over the Christmas period
uh that along with many other
disruptions to people's lives over the
next few days are the unions holding the
country to Ransom
well I think the unions are trying to
get a fair deal for their members and
you know right and you mentioned right
across the economy uh working people are
suffering the cost of living crisis many
of them haven't had a pay rise for uh
several years in in the public services
and most workers have had below
inflation pay Rises every year under
this government and you also heard that
the reason why these uh strengths are
not getting resolved and people you know
are able to call those uh little strikes
off is because the government are
effectively blocking the strengths uh
being a council so I think there is
certainly a a huge challenge here there
is certainly a massive impact on the
economy but the only way that we're
going to resolve these issues is if
people do get around the table and find
a solution and don't block and that the
government doesn't block Solutions when
they are on the table
the ambulance driver strikes is a one
that is causing a lot of fear for a lot
of people just talking to uh the unions
for the doctors who were saying who said
the chief believe people probably would
die over the coming weeks because of
what is happening are you worried that
there's going to be a shift in public
attitudes to to what is happening if
people start losing their loved ones
because of this
well I I think people are really really
worried about what's happening in the
Health Service already before the
strikes we've seen an ambulance uh
ambulances were in six eight hours
before they can drop their patients off
while you know get the patients into
some emergency we're seeing people
waiting longer than they have to in a a
and in other parts of the Health Service
what what we're seeing is uh Public
Services across the board that are
falling apart of the scenes and so I
think the public are genuinely worried
about the level of public service and
it's a real I think Mark of Shame on
this government that those dedicated
professionals that we all rely on and we
all clapped through the pandemic field
so desperate that they have to take
industrial action just to get the
government to hear their experiences uh
both personal in terms of their wages
but also the services that they provide
that that's what people are going on
strike for in order to protect services
and ultimately give a decent service to
to those to those members of the public
and I think they get that I think that
they see where uh default lines here
they support uh the workforce and they
really want the government to get around
the table and find a solution at the
moment the government doesn't seem
prepared to do that yeah do you accept
though that what you're asking for is
unrealistic five percent on top of
inflation is a huge sum the ifs thinks
it would probably cost every household
in the country about 640 pounds given
the cost of living crisis this just
isn't a bill that the the country as a
whole can afford
well I think you're right so focus on uh
affordability General and that the fact
is uh the government are making
political choices uh around taxation if
they were to to tax profit capital gains
tax and share dividends at the same rate
that they're taxing wages they would be
able to afford to give every public
service worker a fair pay rise but
they're choosing instead to effectively
stuff the pockets of the wealth for you
who get their income from profits and
shares and make and and squeeze the
purses of the workers who are generating
those profits so these are political
choices the government could make
different choices that would allow them
to pay public sector workers properly
what they're choosing not to do so you
know fairness the government though they
did increase taxes on uh some of those
higher salaries uh in the the recent
budget
um the ifs also uh as you know
independent and well-respected body they
say that when they look at a
remuneration because the argument that
we hear from from unions like yourselves
that the public sector pay isn't isn't
keeping Pace with private sector pay the
ifs says when you look at the Gap in
total renumeration accountable
differences in both pay in the private
sector as well as differences in
employee characteristics so things like
pensions Etc the public depart private
differential is about six percent in
other words total remuneration for
public sector workers according to the
ifs is an average six percent higher
than for those who are privately
employed so you know they would say that
and the government would say that you're
not taking into account the other
elements of working for the public
service that our benefits and and that
perhaps that is a bit a little bit
disingenuous you know when you're trying
to put your case towards the top of the
public
well the reality is that workers and
local government workers in health and
workers in in a civil service at the law
end of those pay rates uh bumping on
just above the national minimum wage
just above in in pennies now we're not
talking about pounds or pennies above
the national minimum wage so there is an
absolute argument for improving pay in
the public sector but there are lots in
the private sector who are also on on
those salaries aren't there yeah
absolutely and we think our own workers
should have a fair pay rise whether they
work in the private sector or in the
public sector and public sector workers
have seen their pensions attached year
on year so people are paying more now in
their pension schemes and enjoying a
poor attention when they retire the fact
is every year every single year under
this conservative government public
sector workers have been made worse off
and private sector workers have been
made much better off either under this
government they're trashing the economy
uh they're they're taxing uh system
favors the rich and not the working
class no these are choices that the
government are making and public sector
workers reserve a fair payrolls Okay
Kevin Rowan head of public services at
the TUC thank you very much
time now for a final guess and there
were yet more allegations of misconduct
in Westminster this week from a
conservative MP losing the whip
following a complaint made to police the
claims of sleaze around the awarding of
PPE contracts during the pandemic it all
adds up to a constant drip drip of
stories ranging from bullying and
harassment to rule breaking and serious
sexual misconduct in recent years so is
there a particular problem in
Westminster politics and what is going
wrong well one person who might have a
view Sonya Khan who was a special
advisor to not one but two conservative
chancellors and Philip Hammond and Sajid
Javit she settled an unfair dismissal
claim having been marched out of Downing
Street and has spoken of the environment
of bullying and bad behavior uh very
good to talk to you today Sonia
um are you surprised by what seems to be
a constant stream of these kind of
allegations and cases that are still
coming out
um I'm not surprised I think that over
the last few years we have created
um a system where actually if people
feel much more empowered to take action
I mean it's not perfect but I think
um what we have is a Westminster that
hasn't really changed but we have um a
group of people now
um that can work together or have seen
um examples of other people who've taken
action and feel comfortable to be able
to say actually this behavior is not
okay this isn't acceptable I feel like
there is much more of a standard now
about what good and bad behavior looks
like um in Westminster whereas I don't
think that quite existed before but we
have had a number of inquiries you know
Dame Laura Cox inquiry 2018
um 2020 to Alexander Allen's report and
to put into pretty Patel now there's
some inquiring to Dominic Robb do you
think that they actually change anything
do you think they're worth the paper
they're written on
um it's I mean it's difficult to say
because in my circumstance I had to um
take the legal action in order to to
change behaviors or to get people to
look at what actually went wrong which
isn't the ideal solution because it's
quite a costly process
um I mean I think in truth we have a
system where the only change that
happens is when it comes to general
elections so I guess you could say
there's a way for constituents to change
who their MPS if they think that
actually the story is about bullying are
right but if you're a victim of bullying
whether you're in the civil service or
whether you're someone who works in
Westminster or quite a junior role you
work in Parliament then there isn't
really a way to change things other than
you changing so often that means people
have to leave their job or they leave
the sector or they go through something
completely different I've known people
who've become doctors or have gone to
work for Charities because I don't like
the culture of of Westminster so you I
guess there are elements that can be
changed but for most people the the way
that change happens is they have to
change the role themselves and we've
seen of course a number of politicians
male and female saying that they're not
going to stand again in in this current
election but quite a lot of them
relatively young female MPS do you think
political culture could have played a
part in that
I do and I think that the scrutiny that
many female MPS have is far greater than
male MPS who've seen people's romantic
lives uh being dissected uh in
newspapers we've seen some of their sort
of fashion choices dissected and I feel
like for a lot of them it must come to
the point where they decide that they
don't want that anymore
um so I I can totally understand that
and I can also see why politics perhaps
doesn't always feel very rewarding in
this current environment and how maybe
they can affect change in perhaps
slightly different roles
there will be some though that will say
look you know politics like lots of jobs
is a high pressure environment there are
going to be big egos there are going to
be long hours people are going to be
exhausted strong personalities it's all
part of the job if you want to work in
that environment you just have to
toughen up a bit
um there is that sense and I would argue
you can have that in so many careers you
can have that in law you can have that
in medicine but the biggest difference
between those careers and politics is
that it isn't meritocratic so you can be
the smartest person you could have
dedicated your life to public service
for 40 or 50 years but that's not
necessarily what's going to help you
succeed it's a very very reputation
heavy and I think that's where the
frustration can come from from a lot of
people so it's much more about do you
know the right person are you in favor
with the right person or do your actions
sort of work for the current government
um and and I can see why that element of
the job perhaps isn't very attractive
and I think that's perhaps a distinction
to meet between other careers that you
can succeed just by working hard whereas
in politics there's a bit more of a game
to be played
so it seems that you're suggesting it's
riddled with cronyism
I mean I think that
that as well it's very much based on
kind of who you know rather than than
what you know I mean you do need a base
level of um probably intelligence to be
able to get on especially with scrutiny
that comes through select committees and
whatever but yeah primarily it's are you
have you voted the right way do you know
the right people
so it's it's who you know rather than
what you know there is still no
independent advisor on ethics Liz trust
said that you know she knew what ethics
were and she didn't need one do you
think that that there should be somebody
in place in that role and soon
I don't think that an advisor on ethics
is going to fix the system that we have
I think it's much more structural than
that
um I think I've said before that there
are always people at the bottom in
politics and I don't think you can
change that but you do need to look at
how do you create a system that
encourages those people to speak up and
and does in a way that makes them feel
very protected so I'm talking about you
know lots of the Pas secretaries kind of
the people who bear the brunt of bad
behavior often
um and I feel like sometimes these roles
only focus or engage with the very very
seniors so how much having an
independent advisor will help perhaps
those who are going to struggle the most
I I don't know I feel like there's a
much more sort of wholesale change that
needs to happen but it needs to be
bottom up and and you yourself have
moved on you've got a new career uh
you've got a a new baby if you've known
how bad it would be and and looking back
would you have done it would you have
would you have still done gone the route
you've gone
um it's it's a good question I mean I do
have a baby and I'm not sure I would
want my sons to take the same path but
at the same time
um I feel really proud to have achieved
change whether it's change for women or
people in poverty or whether it's trying
to just represent a different class of
people
um to senior people like Prime Ministers
and chancellors so I guess that's a half
answer I'm grateful for what for what I
was able to do but perhaps right now I
wouldn't be encouraging a small child
into politics and this
um there is a major change about how
people are supported
case and you can't it's been lovely to
talk to you thanks a lot former special
advisors Saji Javed and Philip Hammond
thank you
well that is it for this week's Sophie
Ridge on Sunday with me Jane second in a
moment after the break we'll run through
today's interviews and see what we've
learned I'll be joined by our Deputy
political editor Sam coats thanks for
joining us this Sunday morning
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning and welcome to Sophia Ridge
the take this morning with me Jane
second this is where we look in more
detail of what we talked about with our
guests in the last hour and help us do
just that I'm joined by our Deputy
political editor Sam coats and Sam what
did you make of the show did I do all
right
foreign
I was just watching the show and looking
at the messages that are coming in and
reading the Sunday papers and my
goodness it's just rubbish being Richie
sunac at the moment you know because of
the standard set this year in British
politics I mean 2022 has just been one
hell of a year we've ousted one prime
minister we've ousted a second prime
minister and I think and that feels to
everybody like we've a exhausted
ourselves and B raise the bar but as to
what you might call a crisis but but
listening to those interviews there's
just no bit of Rishi sunax time intent
in number 10 that feels like it's going
particularly well his political
inheritance is Dreadful uh he is having
to cope with these public sector strikes
where bloody you know the reason as we
were talking about earlier that James
cleverley isn't open to more
negotiations I think is that the
government just think there's no money
left to gave inflation or even near
inflation increases to all sorts of bits
of the public sector because of all of
the spending partly that you know Rishi
sumac was the author of during the
pandemic uh and and afterwards and so
he's stuck between the unions and the
public finances in some senses
um stuck between the unions and his own
party one of the big things that's going
on behind the scenes this morning is
that once again the conservative party
is in massive Revolt this time over tax
there's a big letter just gone out from
40 Tory MPS complaining that the tax
rates that he set in the Autumn
statement just three or four weeks ago
are too high there's another big
campaign effectively targeting him led
by pretty Patel in a massive Tory donor
called Peter crudus basically suggesting
uh that his government is taxing too
high and that in some way he's an
illegitimate leader so you've got
political problems you've got policy
problems there are very few friends his
political inheritance from Boris Johnson
and Liz truss is Dreadful he's lost
every demographic age-wide except for
over 65. it is just miserable and that's
even before the next two weeks of
strikes everywhere you look start to
begin
it's not a great couple of weeks ahead
to look forward to Before Christmas is
it Sam well let's start with my
interview with the foreign secretary the
Royal College of Nursing is off to call
off these strikes this week if the
government agrees to Serious
negotiations overpay I pressed James
Cleveland on why the government isn't
just sitting down directly with the
unions to open negotiations and prevent
the walkouts
that is the role of the independent pay
review body it's the the clues in the
name it's independent and it reviews pay
Awards you control the purse strings
they're not the ones who make the
decision it's it's a recommendation they
make it's up to the government it's a
recommendation and a recommendation it's
a recommendation and a recommendation
that we have um uh agreed to implement
but it just doesn't seem that there's
any way to resolve this then if the
government is saying we are simply not
going to move from what the independent
pay review body says we are not willing
to negotiate at all with the nurses
about about what they believe sorry this
question is going around in circles the
point is getting a straight answer sorry
you're not getting an answer you like no
but that's different I'm giving you a
story something to understand why the
independent paper review The Independent
pay review bodies were created to
resolve differences between uh the uh uh
the the bodies that seeking uh pay
whether they be in the health profession
teaching question other professions and
the government that hold the purse
strings they are the adjudicator they
were created they are independent of
government they are staffed by experts
that is why they exist they make
recommendations and in this instance the
government has accepted the
recommendation fully but the nurses
don't accept it and it seems therefore
that there is no way to move forward
from this well as I said the the health
secretary has set his door is open uh he
wants to talk to the health
professionals about how we how we drive
performance the NHS how we make sure
that it's a job that uh that they want
to uh they want to do that all all these
things but
as I say the independent pay review
bodies do what we ask them to do which
is to review pay independent of the
government we accept their
recommendation
well let's get more uh from Sam codes
and and you know the independent peer
review bodies aren't an arbitration
service are they Sam they set these
levels they recommend these levels to
the government but the government just
doesn't seem to think it should get in
between them and and for example the
nurses
that's right Jaden and that was a
frustrating listen right hearing those
exchanges because you were absolutely
right all the independent pay review
bodies do it is a very important role is
to come up with a figure a
recommendation and then the government
decides what to do next and the
recommendation was made for nurses back
in June it was the 14th of June that's
when they published their pay review
report and then it's entirely up to
ministers what to do next looking at the
public finances by the way ministers do
have an input into the pay review bodies
but then they get to say uh what happens
next and it's completely normal that
ministers vary what the pay review
bodies do ministers since time
immemorial have been doing it and
critically and this is the difficult
thing for this government that's exactly
what they've done up in Scotland where
by the way there are no nurses on strike
this Thursday because the Scottish
government went a bit further but in
England in Wales and in Northern Ireland
those administrations decided they
weren't going to offer that little bit
more and as a result the RCN the Royal
College of nurses and Unison are
pressing ahead with that strike action
so James cleverly there sort of
sidestepping and trying to not really
get into a discussion about whether or
not if the unions are serious about a
below inflation pay uh settlement then
what that might mean now I I have to say
that off the Record to The Observer the
union seemed to be hinting that they
would accept a settlement that's a
little bit lower than the inflation what
I can't find is an on the record
commitment uh to that and in some places
this morning uh Union representatives
are still talking uh for uh above
inflation uh pay settlement and you
heard uh the BMA representative on your
program also talk about the need to get
back some of the play that they lost
because of inflation over the last few
years so it's not quite clear to me
exactly what the unions mean by
potential actually accepting a below
inflation pay settlement so we ought to
be careful about taking that on trust
until we see exactly what that means but
but we can't even get there because
ministers don't even look like they want
to engage on that labor as ever trying
to uh force apart some division
um where's treating out and about
earlier this week seeming to say that
maybe there was a little bit further
that he could go beyond the pay review
but he's a little bit less Keen to to
Echo that language uh today uh but I
think that as people enter this
miserable Fortnight and look forward to
a Grim start to 2023 I think that just
the Specter of
um ministers not talking to the unions
will come back and back and back indeed
well they're all College of nursing's
offered to hold off on strikes if the
government comes to the table as you
were saying to negotiate overpay was
something that I raised when I spoke to
Labor's Shadow Health secretary West
Street in he said it was too good an
offer to turn down
the Royal College of Nursing and Unison
have said just uh last night that if the
government is prepared to sit down and
talk about pay and all of the other
issues they will suspend strike action
this week now I think that is an offer
that is too good to refuse and I want
the government to explain why they're
not prepared to sit down and even talk
even though they know that patients will
experience real disruption as a result
of strike action
and some of our viewers especially those
of in Scotland will know that they are
closer to a pay dealer there 7.5 percent
is what's been offered up there and
there is there is some speculation some
of the papers that that may be the sort
of ballpark that maybe some of the
unions are willing to to start these
negotiations with the government at
yeah and we always talk about pay
negotiations just about the figure don't
we um possibly 7.5 possibly something
else but the the sort of Secret of pay
review negotiations is it's often as
much about the terms and conditions and
changes to working practices uh and a
far more complicated set of uh changes
to contracts below the surface as much
as it is about that headline figure and
of course in Wales there's a Labor uh
Administration there there are strikes
uh heading uh for nurses strikes heading
uh there too and announced much after uh
the English ones they're also going to
be strikes in Northern nine so it's not
it's not like the government in London
is the only one to be um facing this
difficulty and feeling its way through
this problem uh but yeah there is
essentially
um a challenge that nurses feel is
unignorable the uh with inflation over
10 percent uh they they they just want
to raise that um raise that offer the
the problem that you've got politically
is that for whatever however where
streeting might say uh Minister should
get to the table they need to go they
need to go further labor isn't setting
the bar they're not saying we would uh
offer 7.5 uh inflation or anything else
um they too politically are trying to
tough this out and whilst putting the
pressure as much pressure as possible on
the government and trying to avoid
actually saying what they would do which
is why actually interviewing labor front
benches could be a somewhat frustrating
task when it comes to this because it as
we've often talked about before on this
slot there is a there's a great secret
behind the scenes in British politics
which is that ministers do expect
inflation to come tumbling down very
quickly uh next year with it returning
not that far off from Two and a half
three percent by the end of next year so
they are hoping that this issue of
public sector discontent goes away
fairly soon in the new year but that's
all predicated on essentially the
problems with Russia and energy prices
the key Cornerstone that's driven up
inflation and problems with trade with
China going away but on neither Ukraine
and Russia nor on Chinese trade does it
look like actually the drivers of rising
inflation are particularly easing at the
moment so who knows what's going to
happen next year it may be a bit of
Wishful Thinking both on the government
side and on labor side that this isn't
going to be an issue before too long and
in which case people might be pressed
further and if labor don't have more of
a concrete offer perhaps that could come
back to trouble them but at the moment
this really is the government's problem
and I think people will be looking at
them day to day because they're in
charge and the strikes are starting this
week okay okay Sam uh stay with us we're
going to take a short break but we're
going to be talking with Sam a little
bit more about the conversations we had
this morning with James cleverley and
we're streeting stay with us
foreign
[Music]
of people who do follow Fitness
throughout the year stop during the
winter it's darker it's colder that sofa
seems to get you sucked in with a cup of
tea and a biscuit watching the TV but
it's really important and not just for
physical health but for mental health
that's why we do all suffer from from
getting sad in the winter I do have a
few tips on some strange ones you know
fomo the expression Fair missing out I'm
going to change that to a positive so
the first one be flexible try and change
your working day around get up early get
outside feel the natural sunlight and
and the nature of outdoors and use that
the other one is have an outdoor lunch
be prepared in the morning make a hot
flask of soup or anything take it out
and just get outside at lunchtime that
will inspire you meetings on the Move we
are a cafe culture society which I love
coffee but get a take away reusable cup
and and walk walk and talk change the
way you think about how you do physical
exercise in the winter and the other one
is online during the pandemic so many
professionals put their programs online
so carve out 20 30 minutes an evening to
just get those endorphins going because
like I said it's not just what you need
physically it's mentally staying strong
and happy during the colder months we
have so much variety to what we can do
get outside and be active get that heart
rate up I always find setting a goal
helps so I'm a ski racer I think about
right my first trip to Austria Backtrack
on that how can I prepare physically for
that so goals really help and Community
find yourself a community I actually use
Instagram for this my Instagram
followers are accountable for me getting
outside and being active so find people
who you can train with who say Hey
listen I'm not up for it today but are
you still going because I'll join you
very very important everyone over
indulged at Christmas that's why we wear
these big woolly Christmas jumpers
that's totally fine you've got enough
time it's not it's not really about how
you feel aesthetically or look
aesthetically it's about the health
benefit fits and obviously I'm so
fortunate to to be able to ski in
Austria for the whole winter and be out
there and and have that goal and that
motivation not many people have that but
it's about knowing that you're doing
this for your long-term benefits I'm in
the man Rasheed and I'm Skies north of
England correspondent
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Sophie Ridge on Sunday
the take this morning with me Jane
second and this is where we take a look
back through the morning's interviews
with analysis from our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates well earlier we spoke
to the British Medical Association on
the program and it's Deputy chair Dr
Emma runsberg she's hit out at West
streeting saying that comments from the
shadow Health secretary on improving
standards in the Health Service were
disappointing it's something I raised
with Mr streeting
but it's unacceptable that people have
to wait on the phone at eight o'clock in
the morning to get through to GP I have
been treated like some kind of heretic
by the BMA and I'm afraid
um you know I do understand the pressure
that doctors are under they do a very
difficult job against very difficult uh
backdrop but what I'm saying is if we're
putting investment into the NHS as the
next Labor government will we have got
to expect a better results for patients
and ultimately it's my job to be the
patience Champion I'm a patient myself
I've had great experience on the NHS
I've also had not great experience on
the NHS I want to make sure that
everyone in this country gets a great
experience and that we've got an NHS
that's fit for the future
uh and let's bring in some codes and
South it was really interesting because
his article that today he talks about
the nshs uh not being a shrine which
really struck me as something you know
coming from from a labor politician this
is a man who's who's fighting cancer
fought cancer had real close dealings
with the NHS recently and saying that
he's not scared to take on the unions
that's right and he did so in the Sunday
Telegraph so that is effectively a
message that he wants to get across to
current conservative voters to make it
clear really I mean there's a piece of
very crude politics and we can see it
from space can't be Jane uh labor often
accused of being too close to the unions
um and what's interesting is that the
government hopes that this is a wedge
between labor party and the voters to to
highlight those links and so what's
going on is that we're streating and to
a certain extent kirst armor but but
West racing really in the lead with this
is trying to put just that little bit of
distance between uh the front bench the
labor front bench and key unions now why
might they be able to do it by be
wanting to do that at this point well
clearly the strikes are first and
foremost in people's minds and if you
just look at the most recent polling
since the summer a yougov poll has found
that there's been an eight percentage
Point increase in people that think that
trade unions have a negative uh role in
public uh in public life effectively
unions were favorably viewed now they're
pretty much half and half level level
pegging for those who think that they do
a good job and those that think that
they do a bad job and that that change
is inescapably linked to the wave of
strikes that's going on there is also
more people who believe that the unions
are able to strike too easily and you've
got the government looking to sort of
capitalize on that by potentially in the
New Year bringing forward legislation to
tough and strike laws although we don't
know uh quite how they might do that at
this point so labor trying to just uh
sort of come off the hook of looking
like they're in the Union's Pockets by
refusing to agree with their demands
about increasing public sector pay as we
were saying before the break in line
with inflation and just tonally look
like they're distancing themselves so
that they aren't just uh speaking up for
what they would see as vested interests
for the staff rather than the patients
and that's the kind of job of work that
when streeting was trying to communicate
very clearly is help as you say that he
has personal huge experience of the NHS
as somebody who had to be treated
successfully for cancer uh three or four
years ago and that he can speak with
personal Authority on this but there's a
political job being done here which is
just to detach a little bit more uh for
labor from the unions because that's the
link that the conservatives will
complete will seek to highlight as much
as they can in the coming weeks but of
course also during the course of that
interview I pressed them on the labor
party's dealings with the unions in
terms of funding and he said you know
that he was really proud that the unions
had supported labor for so long it was
why the labor party came into existence
no signs that labor party was going to
step back from a large amount of its
funding coming from the unions
absolutely and we saw that um with some
electoral commission figures that were
out last week there was just a huge
proportion of Labor funding still comes
from the unions and despite some saber
rattling over the last few months that
the unions might reduce the proportion
of funding for the labor party we
haven't yet uh seen that uh and so the
late buddy is uh in need of that Union
funding and keeping them sweet uh
despite that little bit of distancing
remains uh a priority so it's a
difficult diagram for labor front
benches as uh as as the interviews
showed it really is isn't it
um Sam really good to talk to you thanks
very much for joining us on the take
we're going to be talking more in a
minute we're doing a podcast when we
come off air which you can access later
on so please feel free to join us for
that so that is it from Sophie Ridge on
Sunday and the take this morning I hope
you've enjoyed our morning interviews we
are not back next Sunday well I
certainly am not anyway uh back in the
new year so do join Sophie for that and
have a very pleasant Christmas for those
of you who won't be joining until then
thanks a lot
thank you
[Music]